je trouverais c'est dans ce tout nouveau
cadre sécurisé où il faut montrer patte
blanche avant d'entrer que la maison de
solange vient de déménager cette
structure de l'uefa existe depuis 2014
et s'adresse aux femmes victimes de
violences conjugales
si c'est pas un centre d'hébergement il
faut bien noter donc nous avons eu une
petite salle de repos qui était destiné
aux femmes qui veulent prennent enfin
d'un moment de répit
donc si nous avons un petit lit en
général elles ont des enfants
l'ancienne maison de solange était à
coridon la nouvelle au centre-ville se
veut plus accessible car la demande et
la détresse des femmes sont importantes
en 2016 la structure a reçu plus de 3000
appels et près de 1500 visites depuis le
début de cette année 198 nouveaux
dossiers ont déjà été ouverts par ce
niveau là quand la femme vient d'avoir
une agression des problèmes relativement
ingérable donc l'écoutante la prend en
charge dans toute la confidence
au total la maison de solange rassemble
une dizaine d'intervenants extérieurs ou
permanents dont trois intervenantes
sociales mais aussi de nombreux
bénévoles
l'idée étant de favoriser la
reconstruction des femmes victimes de
violence en les aidant à retrouver leur
confiance en elle alors là nous sommes
dans la grande salle c'est un adieu un
atelier de repos et d'activités diverses
donc nous avons leur coin bibliothèque
nous avons fait ce pari de rapatrier ici
les entretiens individuels des
intervenantes sociales et ensuite parce
que c'est un lieu
idéal pour pouvoir mettre en place des
ateliers collectifs alors nous avons
plusieurs ateliers qui ont déjà démarré
d'autres qui vont se mettre en place
comme la sophrologie
mais aussi jardin nature santé bientôt
krav maga
ce nouveau local plus grand plus beau et
mieux situer représente tout de même un
coût pour lui fm qui rappelle qu'à ce
jour ses principaux financeurs que sont
la caf et la ctm la halle est encore
sans réponse sur le budget 2010 est pour
rappel nous sommes à deux mois de passer
en 2018